Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Levez la main, si vous avez été triste
au moins une fois dans votre vie.
Maintenant, levez la main
si vous avez été dépressif
ou si vous connaissez quelqu’un
qui l’a été dans votre entourage.
Merci.
Je vous félicite
et vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce que nous sommes en Afrique.
Reconnaître avoir été dépressif
en Afrique est un exercice difficile.
Pour ceux qui ne le savent pas encore,
la dépression continue d’être un tabou
dans nos sociétés africaines.
N’est-ce pas un déséquilibre ?
Être triste,
est un sentiment que nous avons tous
éprouvé au moins une fois dans notre vie.
La tristesse peut survenir à tout âge,
à tout moment et en toutes circonstances.
Souvent causée par des facteurs sociaux,
le regard des autres,
les situations douloureuses.
La tristesse finit par disparaître,
laissant la place à une amertume
à laquelle on finit par s’habituer
et par laquelle on apprend de la vie.
Mais parfois,
la tristesse ne disparaît pas
et devient insupportable à vivre.
Là, il ne s’agit plus du sentiment
de tristesse ordinaire que l’on connaît
mais, d’un problème plus grave
qui touche la plupart des personnes
en silence, dans le monde actuel.
Jeune influenceuse, Digital Marketeur,
étant encore une fille de 24 ans,
je milite beaucoup
contre le cyber harcèlement
et je soutiens l’autonomisation
des jeunes par le pouvoir d’internet.
Je suis Majoie Houndji.
Si je me tiens
devant vous aujourd’hui
c’est parce que j’ai réussi à faire
de mes déséquilibres, des piliers.
Si je tiens debout,
c’est parce que j’ai chancelé et je sais
ce que c’est de vouloir se relever.
Laissez-moi vous dire.
Vous êtes beaux et belles ce matin.
Applaudissez pour vous,
s’il vous plaît!
(Applaudissements)
J’ai une histoire personnelle
à vous raconter
qui, je l’espère bien, saura impacter
dans cette salle aujourd’hui.
Car, en effet, il faut que
les choses changent.
Mes parents ont l’habitude
de me dire qu’enfant,
j’étais une petite fille adorable,
aimée de tous et amoureuse de la nature.
Moi, qui ai un vague souvenir
de cette époque,
pourrais cependant confirmer leur dire,
car, lorsque je compare
mon enfance à mon adolescence,
j’identifie mon adolescence
à l’enfer lui-même.
La raison...
Un complexe qui a été créé,
pour moi, par mon entourage.
La petitesse de mes seins.
Imaginez, une fille de 15 à 19 ans,
sortir dans la rue avec pour objectif
s’acheter quelque chose,
faire des emplettes
pour ses parents ou partir à l’école.
Maintenant, fermez vos yeux,
s’il vous plaît.
Je vois encore des yeux ouverts.
(Rires)
Imaginez maintenant, cette fille
recevoir de toute part des reproches
et des insultes par rapport à ses seins.
Imaginez quelqu’un lui lancer en public :
« Quand est-ce que
tes seins vont grossir ?
Je t’observe depuis des années
et je remarque qu’ils ne grossissent pas.
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a ? Es-tu malade ?
Ou c’est de la sorcellerie ? »
Imaginez une inconnue,
qui sans son autorisation,
décide de lui palper les seins,
et de lui dire :
« Ma chérie, je vois
que tu es une jeune adulte,
mais que tu souffres d’un handicap.
Tiens, tel produit peut t’aider
à avoir les seins de tes rêves
et ainsi côtoyer
les hommes de tes désirs. »
Imaginez maintenant,
la revendeuse de son quartier
qui la voit passer,
chuchoter à ses clients.
« Cette fille, je la vois passer depuis
des années de classe en classe,
mais ma petite fille de moins
de 10 ans, a plus de seins qu’elle.
Quelle malchance, n’est-ce pas ? »
Maintenant, ouvrez vos yeux
et regardez droit devant.
Je suis cette fille
qui était obligée de passer
et d’entendre des tas de
choses malveillantes à son sujet.
Tu sais, cette fille à qui la vie a fait
cadeaux de nombreux stéréotypes.
Malheureusement,
je ne suis pas la seule dans ce cas
car nous sommes dans un milieu
où il existe tellement de préjugés
sur les standards de beauté.
À une époque de ma vie,
ils ont tellement réussi à me faire
douter de moi-même que pour sortir,
je devais mettre ma main sur la poitrine
pour cacher mes pauvre petits seins.
J’en profite pour remercier
ma mère, amie de l’époque.
qui, à chaque fois
me voyait faire, retirait ma main.
Dans le temps, je ne la comprenais pas.
Mais aujourd’hui, je la comprends
et je pense que c’est elle qui a raison.
Alors je te remercie, Elishama,
de m’avoir ouvert les yeux.
Ces moqueries...
Un regard malveillant des autres sur moi,
ont créé un complexe en moi
qui ne m’étais jamais trouvé
de défauts auparavant
au point d’en vouloir à ma vie.
Alors, j’ai commencé par
me cacher de mes parents
pour me mutiler avec tout objet
coupant qui me passait par la main.
Je pouvais utiliser un stylo
ou même une feuille en papier.
L’important était d’avoir mal
et d’avoir l’impression de planer
et de quitter ce monde
rempli de personnes haineuses
et toxiques.
C’est dans état de choses...
C’est en voulant retrouver ma liberté
que j’ai connu un autre type de morphine.
Le réseau social de
Mark Zuckerberg : Facebook.
En 2016, lorsque je venais de découvrir
Facebook pour la première fois,
j’ai pensé avoir trouvé
une solution à mon problème.
Facebook était le seul endroit
où personne ne pouvait voir mes seins,
mais pouvait l’admirer à sa juste valeur.
Alors, j’ai commencé par poser des photos,
par m’ouvrir à ce réseau social
et je me suis faite des amis
de partout dans le monde.
Je me souviens que j’avais une amie
à Madagascar et une en Allemagne.
Pour la première fois de ma vie
depuis mon enfance,
je me considérais comme aimée
et je me trouvais belle.
Mais je ne savais pas que mon monde
féerique était sur le point de disparaître
pour laisser place à un monde
plus obscur que le monde réel.
Tout commence après
un malentendu entre un ami et moi.
Un ami qui décida de se venger
en étalant ma plus grande crainte
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Me comparant à Kate Moss
et à Naomi Campbell,
cet ami désapprouva
le fait que je sois si vilaine
alors que je possédais
un corps comme elles.
« Tu ne seras jamais une déesse »,
a-t-il écrit.
« Songe plutôt à trouver un mari et
à faire des enfants car les gens comme toi
n’ont rien à faire sur ce réseau social. »
Comme vous l’aurez deviné, s’ensuivit
une tournée de publication à mon sujet.
Il y en a qui dit : « Femme ardoise,
femme plate, femme sans seins.
C’est quoi ?
Qui a vendu tes seins ?
Moi, qui fuyais le regard
des autres dans la vraie vie,
je me suis retrouvée à me faire
insulter sur les réseaux sociaux
par des enfants, des adolescents
et des jeunes de mon âge
pour quelque chose à quoi
ils ne prêtaient même pas attention.
Il y avait même eu
des caricatures insultantes sur moi.
Après une de mes tentatives de suicide,
j’ai décidé de reprendre
ma vie en main et de me battre.
Je suis allée voir mon père
et je lui ai dit :
« Papa, je veux porter plainte,
car je ne supporte plus être cible
des haters sur les réseaux sociaux. »
Dans sa grande sagesse
et avec un sourire, il me laissa partir.
Lorsque je fus rentrée,
il me demanda de le suivre
pour qu’on aille voir ma tante.
Je ne m’imaginais pas
qu’une surprise m’y attendait.
Lorsque je partis là-bas,
je remarquai quelque chose de familier.
En effet, ma tante possédait les mêmes
caractéristiques de seins que moi.
Mon père prit la parole et dit :
« Tu vois ? Ta tante a de nombreux enfants
mais, ses seins ne sont jamais tombés.
C’est le genre de seins que tu as.
Mais pourquoi tu laisses
les autres te minimiser ?
Pourquoi tu ne veux pas
être fière de ce que tu as ? »
Mon père ne le savait pas encore
mais il venait de toucher
une partie de mon existence.
Quand je suis retournée,
je me suis tenue nue
devant le miroir et j’ai dit :
« Majoie Houndji,
tu es une très belle femme.
Tu as un joli corps.
Tu as une petite belle poitrine.
Tu as un joli visage.
Tu as de jolies lèvres.
Tu devrais être fière de toi.
Tu devrais être fière d’être unique. »
Vous savez la première chose
que j’ai faite ?
Lorsque je me suis connectée, j’ai écrit :
« J’accepte d’être votre femme plate.
J’accepte d’être une femme
qui a zéro seins.
J’accepte d’être une ardoise. »
C’est vrai qu’au début, ça faisait rire
les gens de me voir écrire à chaque fois
et de mettre « hashtag femme sans seins,
hashtag zéro sein, hashtag femme plate ».
Mais au fur et à mesure
qu’ils me voyaient le faire,
ils ont commencé à me prendre au sérieux
et le regard des autres
a changé vis à vis de moi.
Sans le savoir,
j’étais devenue un exemple à suivre
pour les personnes comme moi
qui se faisaient martyriser
au jour le jour, par leur entourage.
Plusieurs personnes ont commencé
à s’identifier à moi
jusqu’à me demander comment
j’arrive à supporter autant de critiques.
Parmi eux, se trouvaient
des personnes qui ont de gros seins,
un grand visage,
qui sont noirs de peau, qui sont timides
ou qui souffrent d’un handicap.
Il y a deux parmi eux
qui m’ont le plus touchés.
Un jeune homme
qui était atteint de vitiligo
et une jeune femme
plus plate et plus mince que moi.
Le premier, à qui,
j’ai conseillé de faire du sport
et de faire du mannequinat,
excelle aujourd’hui dans la mode
en tant que mannequin professionnel.
Laissez-moi vous dire
qu’il y gagne sa vie.
La seconde,
qui avait perdu confiance en elle
à cause du regard des autres,
est aujourd’hui une Miss de mon pays,
qui a raflé plusieurs prix.
Son rêve, devenir Miss Benin un jour
et je pense qu’elle y parviendra.
Tout ceci m’amène à dire une chose.
Lorsqu’on arrive à donner
le pouvoir à notre complexe,
il peut changer positivement notre vie.
Moi, qui étais une fille
dans l’ombre au début,
devenue virale à cause
du bad buzz sur les réseaux sociaux,
je suis aujourd’hui Web entrepreneur,
Digital Marketeur et chroniqueuse télé.
Je suis suivie par plus
de 80 000 personnes
sur mon compte personnel
et plus de 150 000 autres
sur mes pages et comptes virtuels
Je suis très fière
aujourd’hui de vous dire
que j’impacte positivement
plusieurs d’entre eux
et j’en suis fière.
Parfois, je me dis,
mais si j’ai seulement réussi
à créer un bouclier qui m’a permis
de lutter efficacement
contre le cyberharcèlement
dont j’étais victime au quotidien.
Et m’a également permis à
l’atteinte de mes objectifs.
Qu’est-ce que vous avez ?
De quoi souffrez-vous ?
Qu’est-ce que les autres pensent
que vous n’avez pas ?
Quand vous vous regardez,
que pensez-vous de vous ?
Est-ce vos seins ?
Votre nez ?
Vos yeux ?
Votre teint ?
Ou votre handicap ?
Si des personnes comme Winnie Harlow
ont réussi à faire de leur vitiligo
une marque dans l’industrie de la beauté,
des personnes comme Tara Lynn
ont réussi à faire de leurs rondeurs
une pierre précieuse
dans le monde sélectif de la beauté,
des personnes comme Oscar Pistorius,
ont réussi à faire de leur handicap
quelque chose de grand
dans le monde du sport.
Une comme Kate Moss a réussi
à faire de sa petite poitrine
une marque dans
le monde de la beauté,
mais, pourquoi pas vous ?
Pourquoi restez-vous là
à vous apitoyer sur votre sort
et à vous trouver un complexe ?
Pourquoi déprimer à cause de quelque
chose d’unique que vous possédez ?
La dépression n’est pas une fatalité
tant qu’on arrive à trouver la cause,
le complexe qui nous amène à déprimer.
C’est pourquoi je vous invite aujourd’hui,
à cet instant, de trouver le complexe
et d’en faire une force pour l’atteinte
de vos objectifs et un super pouvoir
pour l’atteinte des objectifs des autres.
Parce que si
vous arrivez à devenir
quelque chose avec ce complexe,
vous pouvez aider
ceux dans votre entourage,
qui souffrent du même complexe que vous,
à pouvoir avoir confiance en eux.
Alors, je vous demande aujourd’hui
de faire de votre complexe
une force et un super pouvoir
pour survivre à la dépression.
Merci.